we didn't have a Dr Fate suit on set so  Pierce Brosnan didn't wear a suit or  didn't have a cape a golden cape and all  that was added at CG and says post the  execution is yeah we could definitely  make a CG suit no problem but it's also  integrated it with the character for  instance you know as he turns his neck  or he says certain syllables you know  his out of apple is going to go back and  forth up and down his neck his veins are  going to come out so there's a lot of  anatomy here and there's a lot of shots  that are really close up on him and and  it's supposed to be skin tight so it's  it just needed you know artists to go in  there and manually kind of craft the the  suit against his neck in such a way to  make sure that it works with his  performance of whatever he's saying or  how he moves his head and you know  something as simple as that you might  think that's a simple effect right but  there's a lot more hands that go into  that just to make it look just right